why the coid vaccines were 100%
effective and what they used to make
that distinction it's not no like
explain that explain that because it's
such a
bizarre the way they do it it's seems
like it should Beal what they
did with the co vaccine is they they
gave the co this is the fiser tri we
know a lot about the fiser tri because
that was the one that was fizer was the
one to get An approved vaccine you know
it got the it did another
trick it got one of its vaccines
approved the kard vaccine but that
vaccine was not available in this
country but they were able to say to
people oh we have a approved vaccine and
that made it okay for the colleges and
everybody else to force you to take an
emergency use authorization vaccine
which is illegal I think he has a really
good handle on this stuff and we were
doing a little background research we
couldn't straight up debunk anything he
said